Welcome back.
We're on problem number 7.
And let's see, they drew a
triangle here, let me draw a
triangle here as well.
It's got altitude like that,
this is the height h, this is
perpendicular, xyz.
They say, in the triangle
above xz is 6/7 of h.
So this right here is 6/7h, h is
the length of the altitude.
What is area in terms of h?
Well area is equal to 1/2
base times height.
And what's the base?
1/2 times the base.
Well the base is 6/7h, and
then the height is h.
This 2 becomes a 1, this becomes
a 3, so I get 3/7
times h squared.
Which is choice B.
Their word is 3h squared over
7, but we know that is the
same thing.
So that is choice B.
Next problem.
Problem number 8.
If a and b are positive
integers, and they say a to
the 1/2 power, times b to the
1/3 power, to the 6th power,
is equal to 432.
What is a times b?
Here I just try use exponent
rules and play around with
this as best as I can.
So if I raise a product of two
numbers that have exponents,
and I raise it to an exponent,
that's like raising each of
these to the exponent.
So this is the same thing is a
to the 1/2 to the 6th, times b
to the 1/3 to the 6th.
And then when you raise
something to an exponent, and
you raise that to an
exponent, you just
multiply the exponents.
So that's the same thing as a
to the, what's 1/2 times 6,
that's a cubed.
And what's 1/3 times 6?
That's 2.
1/3 times 6 is 2.
That's a cubed times b squared
is equal to 432.
And then we could even write
this as, a times a squared
times b squared is
equal to 432.
And then this we could write
as, a times ab squared, I'm
just playing around I actually
don't know if this is going to
get me to the problem, is
equal to 432 So this is
interesting.
We want to figure
out what ab is.
So if we can divide this
expression by some number,
some integer, and get a perfect
square, then we're
essentially done.
So let's just try divide by 2.
What's this divided by 2?
If you divide it by
2 you get 216.
Is 216 a perfect square?
See, I forget.
6 times 6 is 36.
9 and then 160.
No, that's 256.
14 times 14, that might be it.
14 times 14.
4 times 4 is 16.
1 times 4 is 4, 56, 0,
140, no that's 196.
216 isn't a perfect square.
Well let me erase all this.
As you can see, I don't do these
problems ahead of time.
I do them in real time
for your benefit.
I don't even know if I'm going
down the right route, I'm just
taking it cold like you
will when you're
in the mix of things.
What other numbers are there?
Let me make sure my
pen is right.
Is this divisible by 3?
Yes.
What happens when
3 goes into 432.
432 into 3.
It's 100, remainder 3.
13 goes into it 4 times.
4 times 3 is 12.
Look at that, that's
a perfect square.
So we could write this, that's
equal to 3 times 144.
So ab could be 12.
How do I know ab can be 12?
If we said a is equal to 3,
then ab squared, then this
whole term is going to
be equal to 144.
And if this whole term is
144, then we know that
ab is equal to 12.
And that's choice B.
You know, you could have done
it the other way around.
You could have actually looked
at the choices and tried to
work backwards.
I kind of fumbled a little bit
trying to figure out, well,
how can I have 432 as the
product of a perfect square
and some other number?
And you could have tried each of
the choices, squared them,
and tried to see if they
actually went into 432.
And also met the other
constraints, that a and b have
to be positive integers
that are different,
et cetera, et cetera.
And of course if a is 3 and ab
is 12, then of course b is 4.
But we didn't have
to know that.
Alright, next problem.
Invert colors.
Problem number 9.
What is the greatest three
digit number that
has a factor of 10?
Oh, OK, that has 10 as
one of its factors.
For some reason when
I read that it just
didn't register my brain.
So first of all, when they say
three digit integer, we're
essentially saying any number.
So let's say x is our integer.
So it has to be greater
than or equal to 100.
It has to be less than 999.
And we essentially want some
number in this range that has
10 as a factor.
Well, what do we know
about things that
have 10 as a factor?
They end in 0.
10, 20, 30, 40, 50.
They have to end in 0.
So what's the largest number,
that's less than this number,
that ends in 0?
Well, 990.
And that's our answer.
Problem number 10.
Maybe I don't have to
clear this, I can
just do it right here.
Problem number 10.
A recipe for chili
for 20 people
requires 4 pounds of beans.
At this rate, how many pounds of
beans are required to make
chili for 150 people?
So we can make a ratio.
20 is to 150, as 4
pounds is to x.
I just say whatever factor I
have to multiply 20 by to get
150, I have to multiply the
same factor to get to x.
I just set up a ratio.
And if we cross multiply,
we get 20 times x is
equal to 4 times 150.
What's 4 times 150?
It's 600.
Divide both sides by 20.
600 divided by 20 is 30.
We need 30 pounds of beans
if we're going to
do it for 150 people.
Next problem.
Problem number 11.
I'll switch colors.
When the positive even integer
n-- n is positive and even--
is increased by 50% of itself--
so plus 50% of
itself-- the result is
between 10 and 20.
10 is less than n plus 0.5n,
which is less than 20.
That's what we know.
What is one possible
value for n?
So let's do a couple
of things.
One, we can simplify this.
What's 1n plus 0.5n?
That's 1.5n.
And that's -- I'm going to write
as a fraction-- that's
3/2n, is greater than 10,
which is less than 20.
This is an inequality, right?
So we can multiply every term
of this inequality by 2/3.
So 2/3 times 10 is less than 2/3
times 3/2n, which is less
than 20 times 2/3.
So here we get 20 over 3 is less
than-- this cancels out--
n which is less than
40 over 3.
And 20 over 3, this is 6 point
something something.
It's a little less than 7, is
less than n, which is less
than 40 over 3.
This is 13 point something
something.
So just have to pick
any number between,
essentially, 7 and 13.
So 7 is less than or equal
to n, which is less
than or equal to 13.
Any number you picked between
that range would work.
So 10 would be a good number
to write down.
And a very easy way of doing
that problem is just trying
out 10 and seeing if
it worked out.
And it would have worked out.
Anyway I have 10 seconds
left, so I'll see
you in the next video.